you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network we are a
American history podcast each week I man
with hair man with eyes man with one
foot Dave Anthony reads a story from
American history to his to his friend
Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is going to be about it's about
feet that's the ruse
it is about foots okay and called it
quote is jam-packed I'm okay and this is
not going to tickle you present sip
arguments
Gareth yeah Dave um announcement oh yeah
we you got another foot you I did I just
got a foot and gram and during the music
sting great thing sure
intro music sure labeled we have a date
new date to announce what we did or a
tour are touring okay some they're gonna
take us far away
Odie's Angeles California oh no that's
where all those liberal [ __ ] that's
right it's on fire because they deserve
it yeah um how dare you fire you create
a fire I fired the fire now you want
money for the fire I just fired the fire
the fires been fine it's funny
the only time I've ever seen Trump
quickly apologizes when firemen tell him
to [ __ ] off now
you fired Minh so Los Angeles on the
19th of January tickets will go on sale
through the patreon for patreon
subscribers on Tuesday and then on
Friday for the general public and all
the money is going to you getting that
third foot all goes to the third fee
nice to see you try yes you guys they're
still tickets available for our Boston
our second Boston show The Late Show
this Friday or Saturday on the 17th at
the Wilbur we also are gonna be at the
Royal Oak in Michigan on the 30th we'll
be in Chicago on December 1st that might
be sold out it's very very close and
then in December on the 13th we'll be in
Dallas on the 14th we'll be in Austin on
the 15th we'll be in Houston yeah Dallas
we're also Phoenix on January 18th
Tuesday November 13th I'll be at the
Sycamore tavern doing a show called the
dojo at 8:00 I'll also be there Thursday
the 15th at 10 p.m. with boy Sam Tripoli
then November 29th albeit club Garibaldi
in Milwaukee Wisconsin doing a show
their doors at 7:00 p.m.
I've got links to that at Gareth
Reynolds comm all that stuff December 7
than eight albeit flappers at 10:00 p.m.
and then December 27th 28th 29th
maybe 30th I'll be at the American
comedy company in San Diago California
I'm sorry about that it's okay um
anything else you want to tell people
anything on your life you want discuss
no Jose he's got a big climbing post he
fights me and my brother came over last
night and said whoa he put on weight and
I said you know that's not the sort of
stuff we like to hear here at Gare cor
come again we have standing desks so you
know we're burning calories
he's prairie-dogging he's not very dogs
a lot he's a 30% peri date by prairie
dog you mean laying down in a hole hey
you asked me what was new pal I did
we're talking about the situation with
your cat situation what's in obesity
situation is not an obesity situation no
no he's wasting away when people come in
and are startled by the size the
roundness the thickness of your animal
that's a problem my brother is a weight
and Bella sure I've always has been I'd
be considered not feeding him ham and
lasagna hey listen you're talking about
moving away from the Garfield diet you
better go F yourself pal knows what he's
doing August 29th 1963 BAM now now now
Jesus Christ with black curtains I'm
gonna sorta forrest gump the scene for
the audience sure John Sidney McCain the
third sweet bastard was born on a
military base in the Panama Canal Zone
he was born on a military base
yeah so he was this was his destiny oh
[ __ ] yeah he was the middle of three
kids John's family I'm a little worried
about this already you should be yeah
cuz I you enjoy the man I bought oh yeah
I like them okay well good luck with
that John's family had been in the
military sense forever his ancestors
served in every US war from the
revolution to World War two Wow
his grandfather's uncle
created the modern military draft his
grandfather an admiral commanded all
naval war power during world war ii okay
so of course his father was in the
military Sir John admired his father but
they weren't close Jack was an alcoholic
although John was convinced his father
never told a lie okay yeah most
alcoholics stick to the truth scripts
right inspired it's a classic och I was
cheating on you okay I'm sorry Becky I
had a shoot straight John's mom came
from a millionaire wildcatting oil
family wildcatting yeah we do this we
did an episode of wild cats Oh Oh while
chatting right okay
Jack also made Admiral I'm doing heavy
catting yeah okay so his dad makes
Admiral so they're the first father-son
Admiral team to be oh yeah that's right
as a kid John had a bit of an anger
issue I'm starting very young when he
was two he would become so angry he
would hold his breath until he passed
out oh well that's just that's just kids
being kids days that's normal
yeah yes what'd you do magic tried to go
against human instinct it's important
this is land drowning is what this
that's right yeah his parents would then
dunk him in ice water so his parents
would waterboard him to get a breather
yeah they were they they thought the
best way they also invented
waterboarding well if your kids angry
the best way to deal it with is to treat
him like a terrorist or a spot no
absolutely the first thing you do is put
the kid on ice yeah put him in the
champagne bucket I'm at 12 his family
settled in Arlington Virginia okay which
for people who don't know is right
outside of DC right Jack was the Navy's
liaison officer to Congress they
entertained political and military
figures so his job is to Wine and Dine
Congress for the Navy all right right
being a Navy kid John went to a lot of
schools at each school he'd fight the
first kid who provoked him did he think
it was Jail yes he's like what you do in
school did you find the biggest kid you
beat this
not out of it you gotta be the craziest
guy in school yeah that's how school
works hey wait we haven't sworn yet we
could make this a no swearing up cuz
that's these teachers when we were on
tour this is the one they want okay
well then [ __ ] that let's keep going so
so right so quote to impress upon my
classmates that I was not a person to
suffer slights like wow so he really was
taking the prison mentality yes and just
finding the guy in just a hundred
percent
okay he literally walked into every
school was like I'm the not [ __ ] with
you guy yeah and then held his breath
they were like oh just the kids passing
out
oh thank god sweet ice sweet ice Oh
warming embrace of ice my father would
never give he got the nickname McNasty
whoa see so far I'm loving everything
I'm hearing he went to elite all-boys
schools all-white prep schools he was
often disciplined for fighting Wow hey
listen you're in the realm of McNasty
yeah yeah deal with it after high school
John went to the u.s. Naval Academy his
first trip at sea was to Rio okay the
captain had been a student of his father
okay so Wow fast mate studied John
piloted the ship back and forth oh wow
how old he's 18 yeah he's in the Naval
Academy so I think he's he's out of high
school Wow okay in Rio we hung out with
Admirals and the president of Brazil I
mean like any young sure I mean yeah at
the academy John his friends would drink
they'd sneak off grounds and get into
fights he was nearly kicked out of the
Academy for his behavior but his mother
intervened and he was allowed to stay he
just beat up the superintendent of the
Navy John did not like people saying
that he got special treatment oh well
yeah McNasty is gonna have to beat
people people out of that yeah after his
mom saved saved him from getting kicked
out of school
the Commandant told them he was quote a
which John greatly resented okay for
years he heard his family helped his
career and he never got over quote I
grew red-faced and angry every time some
know-it-all told me how easy a life my
father had made for me okay
chipping away Phil Butler who lived
across the hall from him said quote may
I get you anything Master Mason its
master McNasty anything from the poopies
last name yes I've heard of the Butler
family your name is last names Butler
doesn't mean you're shall I measure you
for pants I am Rick tailor yeah that's
fine
I'm Butler I'll get you whatever you
need more ice for your bath McNasty
quote he was a huge screw off he was
always on probation the only reason he
graduated was because of his father and
his grandfather man he would not like to
hear that John proved his doubters wrong
when he graduated 894 out of 899 cadets
hey that's awesome there's five worse
people that's right yeah or four I guess
yes I'm probably usually in that
situation a couple of them got into like
a car or train they're not at graduation
that's right yeah you want to fend
McNasty he went he went to flight school
in Pensacola Florida okay there he
crashed into Corpus Christi Bay on a
flight he was rescued the plane sank a
navy report concluded John failed to
quote maintain an airspeed above the
stall speed that's easy flew a plane so
slow that it stalled and crashed so he
was driving like a senior citizen in the
air it's like I'm like 20 yeah oh boy
but he graduated his signals on what is
he doing with this guy's Christ what is
is he turning or not he graduated in
1960 soon he was on a training mission
in southern Spain where he flew too low
okay he hit electrical wires and I was
the massive blackout a space great LA
Times quote he brought his [ __ ] the
sky Raider back to the
intrepid dragging ten feet of wire he
brought the plane back yeah well it he
just like screwed up a wing and just
dragging back but he flew the plane back
its Coverley fluent electric wire okay
so he's like a cartoon sure sure yep
very much like when a billionaire
decides to fly a hot-air balloon around
the world he severed an oil line and he
and the plane were completely covered in
oil he was lucky to survive okay
in 1964 John began dating Carole Shep
okay ex-model on weekends he'd fly a
navy plane to Philly to see Carol okay
he's like flying into her house yeah one
trip while he was flying back he crashed
so huh at this point I guess I would be
gathering that he has a propensity for
crashing well he's not great at the
flying of planes he seems to be able to
get it up there get up but then uh
staing ups harder yeah is this a viagra
ad yep John said there was an exit there
was an explosion in the engine and he
lost power and he had to bail when the
engine wouldn't restart okay seven weeks
later the Naval Aviation Safety Center
said it could not corroborate his
account
they found quote no discrepancies which
would have caused or contributed to
engine failure or malfunction the report
concluded John had made several errors
and was lucky to be alive okay but two
weeks after issuing the report the
Safety Center revised all of its
findings the accident Admiral pass
that's weird that that would happen
that is weird that that would have sir
ah the second thought it did explode sir
about that he's right the accident was
now due to a failure of a quote
undetermined component in the engine
sure like a commerce ghost yeah engine
ghosts okay any of his three crashes
would have ended almost all Navy pilots
careers nine times out of ten you lose
your wings for crashing one plane let
alone three three right the Spain city
also took the power out of Spain well
that which led to an international
incident
okay would have quote found themselves
as the deck officer on a destroyer
someplace in a hurry
but John had family pull so that's like
the equivalent of when a cop gets desk
duty yeah he should have been in anybody
crashing three planes is not a Navy
pilot they frown upon that in the Navy
yeah yeah it's not great to crash like
if your job is to fly a fly and and land
it but you don't do that that's not good
at the job right okay so for those of us
listening mm-hmm the crashing of the
plane I think what David is saying is is
not what the Navy is after yeah they're
not looking for crashing a plane okay
John now wanted to go to Vietnam to
boost his profile as a pilot okay but
they weren't sending him they don't have
power lines well they weren't sending
him because he'd crashed three planes
right and again just for people who were
joining the Navy not into that not not
that in right so like most pilots John
had a game of tennis with the Under
Secretary of the Navy and there he
talked him into sending him to Vietnam
despite his terrible flight records it's
a hard sport to charm someone point is
it's there's quite a distance it really
is you got to get up there for volleys
at the same time in volleys Holly back
at fourth you know I'm thinking I could
really help in Vietnam I think I got all
the crashes out of my system in 1966 he
was sent to the USS Forrestal in the
South China Sea by January 1967 John
McCain was a lieutenant commander now go
ahead is is it weird that he's being
promoted because of the record I believe
that you're you're I mean I think as a
pilot as you move on as a pilot you get
automatically promoted like pilots have
a higher status okay and then and then I
assume when you go to war you get kicked
up a little bit more sure like he was
going on bombing runs he was doing
things okay
okay in July 1967 he was in the cockpit
preparing to take off from the Forrestal
for a bombing run no one knows exactly
what happened but a missile from a
nearby plane hit the plane next to John
a missile okay from from the Forrestal
okay so it was a day it was from from
the ship there on
blew up one of their own planes some
people some people say that it was an
accident that it just went off liming
hope some people blame John McCain fired
a missile from the ship Adam sent his
own plane he just accidentally hit the
button but so there's a lot of different
ideas that there's no there's no there's
nothing they can verify that John McCain
did that but it's one of those rumors
that's always been out there okay but
the belief is is that it was an
electronic malfunction from another
plane that blew up the plane next is
okay explosions right mayhem
everything's [ __ ] now going crazy
sure he jumped out of his plane he rolls
through the flames and just starts
running amid explosions shrapnel went
into his chest and his legs but he's not
seriously injured others gave their
lives to save the ship they pushed Jets
into the sea to keep from bombs on the
Jets from going off right so the whole
[ __ ] thing's on fire Wow okay you
need to get the planes that have bombs
on them off the ship or they're going to
blow up right and then all these guys
are pushing the planes off the ships
geez Lieutenant Commander herb Hope was
quote cornered by flames at the stern of
the carrier hope hurled himself off the
flight deck into a safety net and
clambered into the hangar deck below
where the fire was spreading hope then
took command of a firefighting team that
would ultimately save the ship now that
guy was three planes away from John John
on the other hand found safety in the
reading room and watched on
closed-circuit television as his fellow
soldiers
saved the Forester he watched on the TV
on the booked on the ship he went into
the ready room and watched everybody
else work to save the ship he might have
thought he was watching a movie or
sometimes heroes will do he might could
have very easily thought that he was
watching a war film true this is a good
one the accident killed 134 men oh [ __ ]
in October 1967 during a bombing run on
a Hanoi a power plant John was hit by a
surface-to-air missile he ejected as he
flew out he broke his right knee his arm
snapped from the force of the wind and
he was knocked
conscious he shoot open he landed at a
lake in the middle of Hanoi he was
pulled out by North Vietnamese and
attacked his shoulder was broken he was
bayonetted kicked and beaten he was
interrogated for four days he might have
been killed but the North Vietnamese
learned that his dad was an admiral okay
and then they found this out because
John told so he named dropped by the way
that would come out real early if that
was me four days is quite a stretch I
know I know he's four minutes before I'd
be like give me a phone I'll call daddy
you're not supposed to reveal that kind
of info but um dropping that [ __ ] right
off here's a picture of a music number
but also I'm not I'm not flying a plane
killing Vietnamese also so it's two
different rude yeah so John was
interrogated and beaten he gave up the
name of a ship the number of the raids
he had flown his squadron number and the
target of his final raid okay or as
Senator Fred Thompson said at the 2008
Republican National Convention quote
when his captors wanted the names of
other pilots in his squadron John gave
them them the names of the offensive
line of the Green Bay Packers that year
in Philly John said he had given up the
names of the Minnesota Vikings offensive
line
how many offensive linemen have to die
for this fib in truth he gave up the
name of a ship the number of raids he
flow and his squadron number and the
final target it was right but why not
switch that up I'm too little distracted
because I heard the Packers after six
weeks
John had lost 50 pounds he had dysentery
his here'd gone white and he was in a
chest cast they tried to yeah those were
normal I mean those are just bad it's
just a bad look yeah let alone
everything Wow
yeah okay they tried to get him to sign
and tape record a confession for his war
crimes he refused and was tortured for
four days until he finally did they put
him in solitary and tried to get him to
sign another confession he wouldn't he
was tortured or put in solitary
confinement confinement for 15 months
holy [ __ ]
yeah so those guys were all really
[ __ ] horribly treated that what was
known as the Hanoi Hilton yeah in
September 1969 Ho Chi Minh died
the Vietnamese treated the prisoners
better after they were allowed to spend
the day in a communal space John his
fellow POWs would reenact entire movies
so he's living like the one I was
watching when the ship was going down or
like there's gonna be one in the future
it's called splash right I'm a mermaid
look at New York my love can you believe
the big city oh my god I just walked
into the bathroom and she's in the tub
with a fishtail could you like could you
bring an act a movie oh yeah
you could yeah what do you want to say
I'll do right now I haven't seen all
right so a what are we okay
that was good hey what are we hey what
are we credit you know where our edits
here today mmm that's reddit that's good
yeah
have you really never sinned dear no
I've seen dear okay not free so in the
States while this is going on John's
wife crashed her car into a telephone
pole did she take down the city's power
I think she was like I love you and
they're gonna throw hard time honey we
have so much in common
I just took down Michigan's power she
had to smash legs a broken pelvis a
broken arm in a ruptured spleen
she spent like those moments where I hit
a joke nicely and then the next line is
like she was dying she spent six months
in the hospital and had 23 operations
over the next two years oh [ __ ] but I
feel like that just means they weren't
getting the operations right potentially
but god oh my 23 operations yeah that's
a lot yeah that's like you're getting a
couple of those for free or having so
many I hope so you get a hospital punch
card yeah they don't do that so in 1970
oh by the way
Ross Perot champion of POWs paid for her
medical care I want to give her all her
money to pay for her bills okay
I'm paid for 24 surgeries I want her to
have one extra she doesn't need any more
surgeries we're gonna give her one more
she doesn't need any more we're gonna
give her an extra finger for what huh
we're gonna change your eye color no
none of that as American people have
spoken okay and I'm gonna do what
they've always wanted we're gonna have a
dog attached to her back
no 724 surgery that's on Ross Perot I
support PETA W more than anybody okay
that's not support put it live dog on
her back and they're gonna become a
human animal hybrid all right and the
dog can boat okay oh well look I paid
for one more no we're not doing one more
I'm gonna have myself attached to her no
yes I am yeah the dog was a jumping-off
point
that's awful now I'm attaching myself to
her then we're not gonna do that she'll
do all the walking and if she gets tired
she'll bend down a little then I'll do
some of the bucket we're not doing any
of this all right well can I just get a
dr. pepper there yep all right I'm a
doctor I disagree come back it moves out
the window mr. Perot
in 1973 John was released after five and
a half years as a Pio w KL was now
different because of all the surgeries
she was now five four she had been five
eight before Wow Jesus yeah so she
government so that's a lot of removal
and posture she'd also put on a lot of
weight POWs were welcomed home as heroes
unlike a lot of other soldiers right
right John wrote a 13 page story for the
US News and World Report the New York
Times put a photo of him arriving home
on its front page at the White House he
got a photo shaking Nixon's hand he took
part in parades made appearances and got
fan mail Ross Perot introduced him to
California Governor Ronald Reagan you're
like this guy who invited John to be the
keynote speaker at his annual prayer
breakfast the prayer breakfast
John's broken bones had not healed
correctly he had three operations and
grueling physical therapy he wanted to
go but his wife was like yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah 20 surgeries 23:24
once I'm fully attached John wanted to
go to the National War College but one
had to be a commander to do that and he
was only a lieutenant commander the War
College yeah it's like it's not like
prestigious most important whatever or
where you go if you want to kill people
great for the government I mean not like
you have a application not like just
randomly killing people on the streets
but like if you want to do it officially
oh right yeah the heroic ones yeah the
one where you're not where you commit
war crimes but you but you're not ever
convicted it's like free killing I feel
like you're adding some personal
attitude he appealed all the way up to
his dad's friend yes John what are you
Secretary of the Navy who somehow
granted his request
sure so John was promoted to commander
and went to the National War College in
1970 and that's usually how most people
get promoted from lieutenant commander
to commanders by asking a dad's friend
oh it is okay yeah all right
after all this physical therapy he
passed the physical to get his flight
status reinstated oh Jesus
there are differing opinions on whether
he earned it or was given special
treatment Wow why do you think people
think he was given special treatment
well Nasty's catchphrase daddy daddy I
want to fly a gun today
I'm very surprised by the nepotism
factor I've ever heard about that Wow
yeah weird you know you didn't hear
anything about John McCain that's
interesting thing about John McCain he
was a senator right mmm he was signed to
the hellraisers training squadron in
Jacksonville Florida
hey that's their nickname the
hellraisers he was very in demand as a
war hero and gave speeches all over the
place he wanted to run for office but
said there was too much competition in
any district he was he was also [ __ ]
tons of women and adultery is a
court-martial offense
Wow so he's still married to Carol yeah
and he's banging everybody Wow okay John
was rumored to have been involved with a
number of his subordinates that's that's
super cool yeah he was promoted in 1977
captain and then to his father's old
post as Navy liaison to Congress oh wow
okay hmm
well how that happened I probably hard
work and sweat
he was basically the Navy's lobbyist
John was one of the most popular navy
liaisons in history
now he's clearly super likable yes
senators and staffers hung out in his
office and had drinks the McCain's
entertained politicians in their home
but if admirals secretary called and
asked John to hold for the Admiral John
would slam the phone down and when it
rang again he would yell into it quote I
hung up you can't presume that I'm as
busy as you are if you really want to
talk to me pick up the phone yourself
and call me now if that was sung well
that's a lot less rude it's weird
ordinarily in the Navy a captain
wouldn't yell that and an admiral right
ordinarily sure because of the exelon of
power that's right right the 1979 John
mint John met Cindy Lou and Jill still
married yes you met Cindy Lou Hensley in
Hawaii she was a special education
teacher former rodeo beauty queen former
USC cheerleader and her dad owned one of
the largest anheuser-busch beer
distributors in the United States okay
so probably like grew up in a
one-bedroom house yeah yeah super poor
right she said she was 24 uh-uh no she
she was 24 he was 42 he told her he was
38 and she said she was 27 oh well
that's fun when you kind of lied to the
middle together that's maybe got a lot
in common
that's amazing flying up about your head
yeah that is kid
over the next year John flew to Arizona
in courted Cindy and he's still married
oh you picked up on that yeah like any
beautiful romance story John proposed to
Cindy while still living with his wife
Carol i i've never we've had that a few
times on the show that move is so insane
to me yeah you're a psychopath I mean
you really have to layer a year while
living with his wife he flew to another
state and courted and dated a woman
while married to his
wife there was a woman who live with
them for a little while and she said
that there was no indication there was
anything wrong between John and Carol
thought they had a wonderful relation oh
my god so she lost four inches from her
overall height and he went to Arizona
every weekend to lose 4 inches in Cindy
who Carol had absolutely no idea quote I
didn't sin SID Cindy must have known
about Carol yeah Carol had no idea quote
I didn't know anything about it I was
pretty much blindsided and it broke my
heart
and March so he's just Jack Tripper ring
from Arizona to wherever he lives with
Carol yeah in March 1980 six weeks after
he divorced Carol John and Cindy were
married he might act up the pieces fast
none of his children Lydia with Carol
attended the wedding for some reason
what'd you think it was I don't know
seeding yeah or just so far away eloping
they might have a love yeah after the
wedding John and Cindy found out about
each other's real ages when the
newspaper published yeah like this
should really be like a movie you have
to have in the media this didn't look
very great mm-hmm so John got out in
front of the story and he spun it and
left out the details that he wanted
secret okay he admitted he cheated and
he apologized okay
the press focused on what a humble
honest interview he gave and what a
great man he was to be so upfront about
this mistake he had made man that is
it's one of those weird standards we've
always had it's like some people will
just get raked over the coals and then
you know some people go on Jay Leno and
just apologize that's right yeah they
had four kids
one Brigid who was adopted from a
Bangladesh orphanage and
1891 his father died and John retired
from the Navy after 23 years he had been
awarded the Silver Star the Bronze Star
the Legion of Merit a Purple Heart and
the Distinguished Flying Cross Wow
John and Sidney moved here is that the
flying cross is the only one I don't
think I've heard of yeah yeah he didn't
get the crashing cross which he should
have gotten three before us he actually
crashed another plane no really yeah he
old you involved about six plane crashes
Oh John and Sidney moved to Arizona
Cindy's father gave John a job as VP of
public relations for the anheuser-busch
distributorship where you start starting
at VP yeah you just walk in there and
find the employee that's weakest and
just beat the [ __ ] out of em and then
your VP that's how it works yeah a
former executive at the company quote
when you have the Budweiser franchise
you don't need PR okay so his role is
vice president of PR yes this role is
role the three money right yeah beer
does not need advertising it no yeah no
you need a PR guy for Budweiser so when
you're a distributor especially so so
John's basically just waiting for
political opportunity to open up okay
and an event in Arizona Charles Keating
jr. and Arizona developer an anti porn
Crusader introduced himself and they
quickly became friends how you doing I
hate porn
I hate porn - I'm really hate it I used
to be a Navy pilot I just really blow
with pornography in January 1982 the
congressman from the district next in
the McCain's announced he was retiring
okay that very day Cindy bought a house
in his district okay just super easy to
do a fever bought a house no it's super
easy to buy one immediately oh yeah I've
Amazon - couple house this week two
months later John announced his
candidacy for Congress okay gentlemen to
say campaign six hours a day six days a
week going through two pairs of shoe
during the campaign shoes he right okay
he bragged how hard he walked and worked
okay he did not mention he spent three
hundred and thirteen thousand far more
than anyone else in the campaign okay
half came from loans to himself and
another 100k frame came from Charles
Keating okay you promise to get rid of
porno right yes you swear to God
pornos bad it's the worst thing ever
planes gay planes planes planes sitting
her dad also invested three hundred and
fifty nine thousand in the shopping
center Charles Keating was building okay
John women served two terms in the house
right so he just [ __ ] rolled through
the house sure almost as soon as he hit
DC the Washington Post in 1982 suggested
he was not a Reagan man but a pragmatic
non-ideological Republican okay but John
was a standard Reagan conservative
backing trickle-down economics opposing
equal rights busing the use of federal
funds for abortions for poor women he
also voted against making making MLK
holiday wait he was Pro he was
anti-abortion very and against a man MLK
holiday sure so he was a typical
right-wing Reagan Republican sure in
John told a joke during a speech in DC
quote I have a really bad feeling about
this
did you hear the one about the woman who
was attacked on the street by a gorilla
beaten senseless raped repeatedly and
left to die when she what the what's
giving a speech with that of a private
function still looks set up is telling a
joke not well did you hear the one about
the woman who was attacked on the street
by a gorilla beaten senseless raped
repeatedly and left to die when she
finally regained consciousness she tries
to speak her doctor leans over to hear
her side contently and she feebly ask
where is that marvelous ape
the walk john mccain good lord
wonder and how do you react to a joke
like that like okay is there a punchline
well why not tell that joke because he
was now running for the Senate
okay John one the the Senate seat in
1987 federal auditors were looking at
Charles Keating's Lincoln Savings and
Loan Keating called Arizona State
Senator Dennis Dee consignee whom he had
donated a lot of money to okay he told
Deakin Seanie to put together a meeting
with the five senators he had given a
lot of money to one of whom was John
McCain before I let you go if you heard
the one about the rapist oh man sit down
pal because you're gonna laugh yourself
up whatever you're next to so John
altogether over his political career had
gotten a hundred and twelve thousand in
contributions from Charles okay as well
as Charles holding you know dinners for
him fundraising today and John had
helped Charles co-sponsoring a
resolution to delay regulations against
savings and loans
it's amazing how it's always been this
way yeah
but at first John did not want to go to
this meeting that Charles wanted him to
go to okay Keating called John a wimp
and John heard about it annex Keating
marched into John's office and handed
John a list of demands that he was going
to show federal federal regulators oh
[ __ ]
John went to the meeting okay it was
with the chairman of the Federal Home
Loan Bank board yeah deikun Seanie and
four senators now that guy the chairman
didn't know anything about the
investigation that was happening so he
set up a meeting with regulators who did
okay and that meeting was with three
higher up regulators at the Federal Home
Loan Bank board in San Francisco
including the director okay the
regulator's realized right away when the
five senators came in
and a state senator that Keating Charles
Keating was trying to show off his power
[ __ ] one of the regulator's William
black took notes
John said quote one of our jobs as
elected officials is to help
constituents in a proper fashion ACC say
CC is the company that controls the
Lincoln savings alone okay
ACC is a big employer and important to
the local economy I don't want any
special favors for them I don't want any
part of our conversation to be improper
immediately the regulator's became
nervous yeah it was a very weird thing
to say yeah Black quote McCain was the
weirdest McCain was wringing his hands
about what to do yeah a stereotype
greedy stereotype the regulator said
this was a very unusual meeting to have
black Senate historians were unable to
find any instance in US history that was
comparable in terms of five US senators
meeting with a regulator on behalf of
one institution and it has not happened
since and that's really saying something
I mean that's bold the meeting out went
on for a while John tried to act like he
was just a senator making sure Lincoln
Savings was quote fairly treated sure
black said that was [ __ ] okay
Keating was a powerful political
godfather in Arizona finally the
director said they were referring the
case to the Department of Justice like
they were not supposed to tell him this
but they just got tired of the [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay and she throws down there
referring to the Department of Justice
there are tons of charges coming quote I
can't tell you strongly how serious this
is this is not a profitable institution
they were told not to tell the savings
alone and Keating anything a month later
the regulator's recommended Lincoln
Savings be seized by the government okay
this is going according to plan yeah
yeah well that's when there was a
shake-up at the regulators office oh my
god
black and the director were out a new
guy took over John McCain the
investigation was moved to San Francisco
from San Francisco to Washington DC and
a brand
odd it was ordered black was furious
quote we were clearly shot in the back
but word got out to the parent company
of Lincoln ACC and they celebrated quote
someone hurled a computer from the
second floor shattering a window Keating
struck a Superman pose and ripped open
his shirt to display a hand-drawn skull
and crossbones over the letters fhlbb
Federal Home Loan Bank board Jesus so
they are Wolf of Wall Street partying ok
her led zeppelin ting potted plants were
knocked over beer and champagne were
spilled out the window get out of here
with your potted plants Keating yelled
get this champagne colder put it in the
McCain bath Wow but - champagne colder
but Keating's businesses were going down
there was soon an investigation into the
five senators misconduct ok John then
showed how he could play the press he
got out right in front of the story and
got himself constantly on TV whereas the
other guys hid from it John was all over
it right he goes on Nightline he goes on
this week David Brinkley he's on
everything and he leaks information to
to show at the Apollo he did show they
bla yeah Bhutto yeah he didn't read the
log no he also started leaking
information about his fellow senators
and Deakin Seany
to make himself seem not as bad like
high school yeah it's unbelievable
Wow it's also kind of Trumpy the the way
that you're like I will tell the
narrative Oh seems troubling okay but
under oath John said he happily nothing
to do with the leaks a congressional
investigator quote McCain was one of the
principal leakers okay so all right so
he perjured himself yeah that you see on
that John underwent two months of daily
televised hearings he would alternate
between tearful remorse
and angry defiance at this political
witch-hunt okay two years after the
meetings during which time the SNL kept
[ __ ] people over after the Senators
got the investigation moved and delayed
the government seized Lincoln Savings
alone okay so they they got it they it
was going to be seized two years before
these senators made that not happen in
that time the savings alone another
savings and loans continued to the
business of [ __ ] over investors
twenty thousand investors had bought
junk bonds believing they were federally
insured they were not their savings were
wiped out taxpayers is what's called
Wells Fargo attacks payers were on the
hook for 3.4 billion jesus black william
black quote mccain saw the political
pressure on the regulators he could have
saved these widows from losing their
life savings but he did absolutely
nothing i should also add that my
grandparents lost a shitload of money
because of what mccain did then was
revealed by the arizona republic' paper
that Cindy and her dad had invested
three hundred fifty thousand in the
shopping center that's not gonna be good
and that the McCain's had made nine
trips at Keating's expense she's three
to the Bahamas well that you've gotta
win the bomb yeah in the Bohemian vote
you have you're gonna go you got a bomb
yeah I mean you're gonna corrupt yeah
but they're a voting part of yeah
Arizona yep John put the blame on Cindy
because he said she was in charge of
household finances she lied to me about
how old she was god damn it she's a liar
it was Carol awful Carol did this that
one that got shorter the shorter one I
need a wife that was five and I come
back she's five four you tell me about
that I got one that's two years older
than she's supposed to be and one that
keeps shrinking when the Arizona
Republic called the reporter asked John
about it and John called him a liar and
said quote that's the spouses
involvement you idiot do you understand
English don't you
Jesus but then pretty quickly John read
the wind and decided to become the best
interviewee possible so him back to his
old mode right charm him get out in
front of it in charming this was one the
love affair between John and the media
really blossomed he's cheating on Cindy
now he held a 90 minute news conference
and answered every single question he
said the shopping center deal was his
his wife and father-in-law and he had
absolutely no idea about it of course
cuz when your wife buys into a shopping
center she doesn't mention it to her
spouse no why would you talk about that
sort of stuff in passing yeah you know
all I did the dry cleaning I went to the
store bought a shopping center got my
nails done got the tires rotated I came
back took a nap Wow yeah that was kind
of the highlight of the day obviously
yeah yeah that's it would you crash
today hon just for planes alright
in November 1990 the Senate Ethics
Committee came up with their punishments
for the Senators we'd uh like to see
your wrists John Gotti Lite scolding
okay for quote poor judgment for
intervening with federal regulators okay
yeah that is in poor judgment Norte John
how dare you [ __ ] humans out of their
money
you'll get one spanking Keating went to
jail for 12 years but it was overturned
on the technicality John was the only
senator who testified in a civil suit by
shareholders of the other senators
refused and the savings and love scandal
the Savings and Loan scandal led to the
failure of 747 savings and loans in the
United States the losses were 160 point
1 billion oh my god
124 point six billion was paid by the
government which is also known so he did
Jane got a scolding right
only John and one other senator were
re-elected the other is retired
John called the quote the worst thing
the absolutely worst thing that ever
happened to me
does that remind you of someone yes
later he would call the Keating five
corruption scandal his quote asterisk oh
my god like you're Barry Bonds wow these
people lost old people lost their
savings do you know what that does no
what you don't if you were raised in
households he doesn't do any sort there
he is
he is the term fail son yeah he is a
[ __ ] fail son yeah okay six months
later John hosted a family reunion at
the Bermuda Naval Air Station okay 11
people from his family came and stayed
in luxury rooms hey yes you brought
marks Hard Lemonade that's that that's
the family yeah no it's me Ross I'm
still here I think I accidentally got an
invitation yeah please go take care of
what I almost swim home uh so eleven
people stayed in luxury rooms for seven
days at taxpayer expense a petty officer
quote sailors had been assigned to be
Cindy's driver and they carried her bags
after she went shopping at the expensive
shops on the island it's like they were
her servants this was the treatment
making a little petty that's the
treatment many VIPs were getting but the
petty petty officer was a whistleblower
and he he alerted the media to what was
happening okay the base had no military
purpose it was a taxpayer subsidized
vacation spot for VIPs over for over two
years 180 VIPs had visited for quote
official business but there was no
business John's group was the largest
group to ever go to the base well that's
pretty cool
yeah biggest one ever this is a pretty
clearly illegal as governor officials
and officers can't use planes and cars
for vacations weird
but the only guy only the guy who blew
the whistle was punished he was sent to
see a psychiatrist which is pretty
common back then in in the military if
you [ __ ] up that's in you say Kai truck
send you to a psychiatrist who says
you're crazy and then they lock you up
like that's the [ __ ] deal so that's
what they're trying to do to this guy
who just told the truth so the
psychiatrist told him quote I've been
contacted before but never in advance by
a fleet commander staff a sender staff
and the Secretary of the Navy staff to
try and influence my evaluation Wow so
John McCain was really was trying to
destroy this guy John never responded to
the allegation that he had tried to get
a whistleblower certified as crazy the
base was closed party base yeah party
base is closed party base is gone yeah
sorry bro but no that's it bro I was
just about to fight a war on this keg
yeah well you got to fight a war on a
keg guy and maybe your own house or
party up in the gun neutral battlefield
it's not a niche about it I killed a lot
of kegs in my place alone I know well
that's maybe that's what you should keep
doing this was one more party party base
so no party base is gone
maybe just one bigger it'd be Rick party
base no party base is closed who's
shotgun won't be a real quick party base
why don't you open a new party base why
don't you call your house party base no
there's no no you can't be alone one
beer party base no let's have a party a
party base okay now we're going back man
[ __ ] this you're terrible soldier John
after all this decided to sell himself
as the guy who was gonna clean up
Washington DC what's wrong I just I'm
not a fan of yours either well no I
think a guy who should clearly be in
prison should be the guy to clean up DC
yeah for the first time he should be in
prison for the keating [ __ ] yeah he
should be in prison for a long [ __ ]
time a long [ __ ] time but right now
he's a senator for the first time he
started supporting a financial forum
took on the meaningless cause of
eliminating congressional parking
privileges I'm here the runway at Reagan
National Airport oh my god he spoke
about how so they parked near the runway
and he's trying to get that but that's
one of the one a few things I go they
should park near the runway because
their congressional people and they have
to [ __ ] travel back and forth the
concision it's also just like I mean on
the tear of objectives it's ridiculous
well you know it gives him it gives it
gives over to the impression that he is
fighting for something he's actually
fighting for absolutely [ __ ] nothing
right in his speech he said he spoke
about how Congress was noble and they
should demonstrate how honored they were
quote to be of the people no matter how
small or symbolic and this was the first
time John McCain was called the Maverick
I miss McNasty in his story by the
Washington Post about how he was a
moderate sometimes fighting his own
party to do what was right okay
in 1991 the Persian Gulf War broke out
and John was suddenly for some reason
the go to war guy for everybody he was
suddenly a national authority on foreign
affairs war was here and it was like the
keening scandal had never happened
campaign again in 1992 John was with
Cindy a reporter said quote at one point
cindy playfully twirled McCain's hair
and said you're getting a little thin up
there John's face reddened and he
responded quote at least I don't plaster
on the makeup like a trollop you [ __ ] oh
my god John didn't even front of a
reporter and a couple of aids yeah a
couple of reporters John tonight he said
it at first but then later said well it
had been a long day and he was she said
I was going bald that [ __ ] I if I ever
called my wife that we would get a
divorce sure I never would but but the
the I can't imagine being in a marriage
where you do that you're not married to
the person you're a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] no that's like poking someone's
chest and
they stab you in the throat yeah it's
completely insane yeah the retaliation
is strong a bit john denied he said it
at first right and then he was elected
okay so he was reelected that year cindy
had two back surgeries in 89 and became
addicted to percocet and vicodin which
was super common back then back
surgeries led to addictions i can't i'm
still in a little bit of shock as to
what he said to his wife he should be
because it's monstrous cindy had a
charity that did medical work in poor
countries and she used the charities
doctors to get scripts geez when one of
her employees got why yes yes we need to
send them all the percocet right now and
the vicodin they're a billion strong 100
strong blue ones oh the strong ones the
180s not that not the 40's yeah up
higher the number really okay and you
know the way I'm taking them don't need
the bottles my body's a bottle I'm in my
body and I will come when one of her
employees started to get wise she fired
him he sued and reported her to the DEA
ad investigation is not public record
okay no one knew about this but then
mccain's asked their lawyer to ask the
Maricopa County Attorney to investigate
the employee for extortion Wow he did
and doing that and he asked the DA to
turn over what they knew now a local
prosecution is public record okay so
they basically that's a misstep a huge
misstep once again John got in front of
the story and spun it and it worked oh
my god the papers wrote about Cindy
strength
Cindy was not prosecuted this trollop
Econ is one of the strongest you're ever
gonna see give me her hand babe don't
touch it
she was not prosecuted and said she was
sent to a diversion program if she'd
been a poor minority and not a senator's
wife she would have been locked up sure
well that's that's how it work by now
John's temper was legendary in Arizona
after a run-in over an Arizona Water
Project and
at the arizona republic' said quote most
of us in the media in arizona thought of
him as a guy who had a terrible temper
occasionally had a foul mouth a guy who
whined and pouted unless he got his way
mccain has a temper that his bombastic
volatile and purple-faced sometimes he
gets out of control he's still holding
that breath yeah it's like it's like the
two-year-old he's still the G when I go
purple I win because people say his
anger stuff is from what happened to him
in Vietnam but that's not what the
history record making tells us and the
Senate John was part of a committee
investigating leads on POWs so there's
all these people that still think POWs
were still there especially in the 90s
it was a big thing right a lot of that
is people taking advantage of family
members but there are a lot of family
members that want to believe that their
son is still alive brothers still alive
it would make sean furious john didn't
think there were any POWs parents
desperate to believe the kid could be
alive during one hearing John yelled at
the sister of an MA soldier until she
started crying later an elderly mother
of an MA a soldier came to talk to John
about her son and they met in the
hallway of the Senate John was livid he
raised his hand as if he was going to
hit her but then he stopped himself his
reporters watching this she was in a
wheelchair oh Jesus so he just grabbed
the wheelchair and pushed her away oh my
god the maverick
that year he was re-elected to the
Senate but he was still funny in 1998
when Chelsea Clinton was 18 that's
somewhere those gorilla jokes cuz those
are killer John told the joke at a
fundraiser quote why is Chelsea Clinton
so ugly because her father is Janet Reno
oh my god I stood like in the Maverick
your old maverick guy I don't think he's
a good roaster that's a fair swipe to
take at the man Junior mm was revealed
PACs and communications executives
donated 20,000 to the Straight Talk
Express okay
that's John's bus bus yeah the company
happened to be waiting for approval for
a television licence from the FCC John
flew on a Paxson jet to a fundraiser and
then sent a letter that was written by a
PACs and lobbyists to the FCC the very
next day then he sent a second letter
and then he called the FCC chair called
John's interference quote highly unusual
he's quote sweating us John also prodded
the FCC for Ameritech when that story
broke they I mean that out of it he sent
out 500 letters to different regulators
in order to kill the story by Biol it by
burying it in a pile of messy
fact-filled documents okay and it worked
so why not run for president John
announced he ran a somewhat populist
campaign stretching as stressing
campaign finance reform slagging off law
lobbyists closing of corporate tax
loopholes and attacking Jerry Falwell
and Pat Robertson as quote agents of
intolerance he was the Pro worst of the
pro-war John made William Kristol one of
his close advisers crystal is renowned
for being wrong about everything John
hired at the bill crystal ball miscible
crystal ball John hired the right wing a
hard right lobbyist as his top foreign
policy guy and he started championing
what he called rogue state rollback okay
he wanted war
Iraq was first up this is 2099 yeah yeah
the media couldn't get enough of John
during the 2000 campaign Tucker Carlson
quote there are the employees of major
news organization organizations who
usually at night in the hotel bars slip
into the habit of referring to the
McCain campaign the McCain campaign as
we as in I hope we kill Bush Jesus
McCain hosted barbecues for journalists
at his Arizona ranch TV anchors and
newspaper reporters would drink beer and
cocktails under the desert Stan as John
manned the grill all buddies he had a
bust called the Straight Talk Express it
was packed with journalists and
basically a constant news conference
with their buddy John in South Carolina
he was asked about a derogatory term he
still used for Vietnamese people oh god
I remember this quote I hate the goop's
I will hate them as long as I live
okay I'm off the straight talking
jumping ship later he explained that he
was referring just to the prison guards
who tortured him quote I will continue
to refer to them in a language that
might offend some people because of the
beating and torture of my friends it's
it is so weird because while my overall
opinion of him was positive though these
are all Trump roots like the it's like
diet Trump like just like the the way
that you are able to manipulate the
system and not apologize when you're
wrong and just hang in there
well thankfully John did not fight over
a nice racist talk express what
thankfully he did not fight a war in
Nigeria right yeah because go could be a
different term wouldn't it yes the word
[ __ ] is in no way a term just applied to
Vietnamese it was first used in 1899 by
US soldiers fighting Filipinos it was
used during the Korean War for both
Koreans and Chinese in 2000 it was being
used as a slur against Asian or Pacific
Islanders John did not care isn't it
amazing that even our racist terms are
racist
themselves yeah like we like we're not
even adept enough to come over yeah
like you were just like lazy enough to
just be like everybody but so he's
offending ya all Asians yeah yes for
sure
all Asians floor sure and doesn't care
it doesn't apologize for it this is all
made weirder because he had spent the
eighties and nineties pushing for
restoring diplomatic relationships with
Vietnam and had been part of the
meetings to do so I assume he didn't
call the diplomats gooks no hope in
February 2000 John dropped out of the
Republican race George W Bush had won
and he'd played dirty he pushed the idea
that Bridgette was John McCain's quote
black love child who Bush Bush that
Bridget the Bush campaign Oh secretly
robocalls things like that Iran put out
the word the Bridget was John McCain's
black love child okay
next John said he would take the so he's
done that was banned of his election he
lost that state and then he was out also
just a great detail to America's
open-mindedness yeah yeah and and that's
Karl Rove who was behind that and if you
want you can see masterclass with having
a good talk yeah yeah yeah next John
said he would take the government back
from big I need to be here
yeah cuz I'm gonna crush you at the end
of it oh it gets so much worse
next John said he would take the
government back from big money special
interests a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization called the reform Institute
was created uh-huh well things that are
always named stuff like that are always
on the up and I am John was the honorary
chair the note take money group the see
money came from a formal Merrill Lynch
CEO which is the best way to get reform
yeah no for sure as a nonprofit the
reform Institute could take unlimited
unregulated donations that John's PAC
could not take strange II strangely all
the Institute's political
positions non-partisan aligned exactly
with john mccain's
the institute paid john for public
appearances his campaign manager was
president and made four and a thousand
in three years the reform institute used
the same office space as McCain's PAC
his re-election committee and a lobbying
firm that he used named Davis manna Fort
hmm there's there's a name familiar live
between 1997 and June 2006 John
collected 2.6 million from
telecommunications media and tech firms
in return he wrote letters to the FCC
for those companies twice the reform
Institute solicited hundred thousand
from cable vision after the CEO
testified in front of John's Senate
Commerce Committee wait what does that
mean exactly that it means that he after
the [ __ ] guy went and testified John
would grill him and then he'd be like
hey man we can actually make this work
John left the reform estate in 2005 but
its goals stayed aligned with his about
the reform Institute the chair of the
Federal Election Commission said quote
appearance of corruption any one kind of
like he went sort of real sassy on a
conflict of interest party of McCain
hello and yet John's image remained the
opposite he was the Maverick he was a
moderate mm-hmm and he cared about
finance reform in 2001 he said quote as
long as the wealthiest Americans and the
richest organ is organized interests can
make these six and seven-figure
donations to political parties and gain
the special access to power that such
generosity confers on the donor and most
Americans will dismiss the most virtuous
politicians claim of patriotism but that
that's what he's doing is what he's
doing right John sponsored the
bipartisan campaign Reform Act and the
Tuffy uy bipartisan also known as the
mccain-feingold act it was to curb soft
money
which is what that [ __ ] Institute is
let him police it would you hmm
911 came finally a feel-good moment
Shawn
then took the lead in pushing for war
with everyone quote there's other
organizations besides mr. bin Laden who
are bent on destruction of the United
States this isn't just Afghanistan we're
talking about Syria Iraq Iran
perhaps North Korea Libya and others he
wants to go to war with everyone I mean
and others leaves it pretty open France
Ireland
he told Jay Leno some other countries
possibly Iraq Iran Syria had Aidid bin
Laden after the anthrax attacks in
America
he told David Letterman that quote will
do fine in Afghanistan why is he just
doing the late-night run sir everybody
loves him okay but he's some liberals
still it's like a weird like but
everybody loves so that's the thing
about McCain he's not like other
senators he's always on those show yeah
he's constantly doing this will do fine
Afghanistan the second phase is Iraq
some of this anthrax may and I emphasize
may have come from Iraq it didn't on
Larry King he talked about sonam's
weapons of mass destruction quote the
Czech government has revealed meetings
contacts between Iraqi intelligence and
Mohamed Atta the evidence is very clear
we so we will have to act on Nightline
quote there is no doubt as to Saddam's
avid pursuit of weapons of mass
destruction and the means to deliver
them exciting and completely not true in
January 2002 John went to the Middle
East on the USS Theodore Roosevelt he
stood on the flight bridge and he
watched fighter planes taking off on
their bombing runs to Afghanistan and he
yelled quote next up Baghdad for the
next 15 months John's hard-on for an
Iraq invasion could be seen from space
that's that's exaggeration okay that's
not a fact well we think we see it but
is he near a forest his top foreign
policy adviser set up a group called the
committee for the liberation of Iraq
the honorary co-chair in September 2002
John said the war could quote be won
fairly easily with an overwhelming
victory in a very short time period sure
he said Iraqi by the way that is true
cuz we're almost done there we are
almost done
he said the Iraqis would treat us as
liberators on October 10 2002 the Senate
rushed to give President Bush the power
to use force against Iraq
John said Saddam quote is on a crash
course to construct a nuclear weapon
well I mean if anyone knows about a
crash course and has developed stocks of
germs and toxins in sufficient
quantities to kill the entire population
of the earth multiple times he develops
nuclear weapons with which he would hold
his neighbors and us hostage just to be
safe we will kill the world twice and
then he said al-qaeda and Saddam work
together all of this of course was a
complete [ __ ] line sounded real real
good time and it did pretty convincing
we did invade Iraq and he was right
about everything obviously yeah we were
welcomed as liberators found the shed in
an hour we found all the nuke yeah the
big nuke a bunker
John still after all this somehow seen
as a maverick such a maverick then in
2004 when John Kerry was running for
president he asked John McCain to be his
vice president candidate and we all know
how that was because John was every
liberals favorite Republican despite you
know everything about him he was now
often on The Daily Show swapping jokes
with Jon Stewart
I assume they never joked about John
spending his career being anti-abortion
anyway John was elected to his fourth
term in the Senate you really taken some
swipes over here Anthony
in 2005 Oleg Deripaska a criminal and
the ninth wealthiest person in the world
also known as Putin's oligarch Oh God
bought MA a montenegro aluminum plant
and privatized it the plant accounted
for 40% of Montenegro's GDP he basically
took control of Montenegro's economy by
buying this plan Jesus
Montenegro then sought independence from
Serbia a multi-million dollar campaign
was run by lobbying firm Davis mana Ford
Davis was John McCain's campaign manager
he set up an intimate meeting ten people
in the world that's where we're at
he set up a meeting with John and
Deripaska at a villa in Switzerland of
course we got to do it classy people
found out about it and John said
campaign leader that's a campaign letter
that said quote any contact between
mister dear pasca and the senator was
social and incidental that lie still
holds up yeah
and now Tara Bosca had been banned from
entering the United States due to death
threats extortion racketeering and money
laundering anything bad no a couple
years before he'd hired one of John's
aides
and Bob Dole to lobby the State
Department to overturn the ban Dole then
got John to promote Montenegro as
independence sure and I'm sure Davis
didn't hurt either
he called it quote the greatest European
democracy project since the end of the
Cold War this is unbelievable I mean
that level the referendum passed a few
months later John celebrated his seven
70th birthday on a yacht hosted by
convicted Italian fellow Raffaello Foley
arey
and his girlfriend Anne Hathway in
Montenegro okay so that's the guy who
just goes today Anne Hathaway yeah as
the Iraq war dragged on and it was a
complete disaster John began pushing for
an increase in troops he wanted 20,000
more in Baghdad and a hundred thousand
over five years opposition ads in the
u.s. called it quote McCain's idea
presidential candidate John Edwards
called it the McCain Doctrine as John
Edwards a good guy yeah yeah good guy
yeah he's also a great family man good
guy John ran for president again in 2006
during the campaign John explained how
he felt in the run-up to the Iraq war
stirring debate okay quote the American
people were led to believe this could be
some kind of day at the beach which many
of us fully understood from the
beginning would be a very very difficult
undertake on politicians went on
Letterman and Leno and they kept
perpetuating
like this well you know the truth is
that yes [ __ ] it also is a testament
to how dumb we are and how we cower
attention spans are that we're unable to
are in reality our job this is the
media's job our job is to react to truth
which were not given yeah if the media
does not immediately say that's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's really hard to remember because
that's how many news what how many
politicians are doing that what he does
so you know it's their job to [ __ ] I
mean is it not every politician it's
Jake Tapper to immediately say this hey
but they're buddies you stay away from
taps he's a straight shooter Ben oh I
took out the thing about him fair and
balanced McCain said he told Bush to
dump Defense Secretary Donald Rumsfeld
quote I'm the only one that said ROM
Rumsfeld had to go yeah the actual quote
from 2004 Rumsfeld is doing a fine job
well yeah but I think a little bit
different read into that fire different
yeah you're right yeah right
cuz fine job is like he's doing okay
buddy you can also hear it let me hear
you go Oh Rumsfeld oh yeah he's doing a
fine job okay yeah I'm saying like that
hash tag I roll okay now I totally know
I'm onboard
ah that's how I said it the Straight
Talk Express was back but this time the
Straight Talk Express was much harder
Josh in that the veep he was writing in
the [ __ ] what's going on expressed
behind them I'm in the like car I'll be
in the crazy mobile with the clowns
John had to walk the fine line between
being a maverick and courting the
religious right now yeah during one
interview he was asked about gay
marriage and said quote I think gay
marriage should be allowed and if there
is a ceremony kind of thing if you want
to call it that then a campaign
strategist whispered something to John
soon during a totally unrelated question
John burst out with quote can I just
mention one other thing on the issue of
gay marriage I believe that people want
to have private ceremonies that's fine I
do not believe gay marriage should be
legal so he just doesn't know what to
say anymore because he's
in court the right that guy was on the
straight talk express say he just came
off this is straight talk not gay talk
people call them out for taking new
positions on many topics John denied it
quote what specific area have I quote
changed nobody can name it okay I will
the Bush tax cuts the estate tax
waterboarding hunting terrorists in
Pakistan kicking Russia out of the g8
troop surge in Afghanistan the GI Bill
storing nuclear waste Yucca Mountain
teaching intelligent design funding No
Child Left Behind offshore drilling his
own immigration policy and withdrawal
timelines for Iraq 21st other than that
he didn't switch on him exactly in 2000
John had denounced Jerry Falwell as a
quote agent of intolerance now he was
given the commencement speech at follows
Loraine University
he saw the support of Texas preacher
John Hagee even though [ __ ] had blamed
Hurricane Katrina on New Orleans
acceptance of gay people well I mean to
be fair we've not proved the contrary we
haven't nobody sat down Katrina for an
interview since also Ohio preacher rod
parsley whom John called John called a
spiritual guide parsley believes America
was founded in part to destroy Islam but
after negative headlines attacking his
image as a moderate John repudiated the
[ __ ] in Parsley's endorsements okay at a
town hall someone asked John about his
policy on Teran John said quote that old
that old Beach Boys a bom-bom-bom
bom-bom anyway when he was criticized
about being so callous about bombing
into the country he said quote lighten
up and get a life when he was asked if
that was insensitive he said quote and
sensitive to what Iranians yes from the
affirmative times yes sir not a
Republican thought John should be
President he once almost came to blows
on the Senate floor with an elderly
Strom Thurmond okay
super Pro someone punching Strom
Thurmond in the face well but if you
punch a Strom Thurmond in the face it's
just like punching some paper mache with
dust in the middle it's just like your
fist goes right through it you like
cobwebs look at all this white hair my
spiders are leaking Strom white spiders
hey
he also got John also got into a
fistfight with congressman Rick Renzi at
one point Jesus
former Republican imagine being an adult
and getting into a fistfight in Congress
probably will get there yeah you sure
advocated yeah former Republican senator
Robert Smith publicly said John's temper
quote would place this country in at
risk in international affairs and the
world perhaps in danger could you just
imagine right Republican senator thad
Cochran agreed quote the thought of his
being president sends a cold chill down
my spine he is erratic
he is hot-headed he loses his temper and
he worries me maverick but the press
loved him he was a maverick John was
asked during the campaign how many
houses he owned and he could not
remember he said he'd have to ask his
staff that's up Wow these are not good
answers let me ask my let me ask the
maids and the quarters where's my boy I
have a small asian boy that tells me
things I have any houses is it sixteen
there it is
Cindy and John owned at least eight one
they bought for their twenty
two-year-old daughter Megan years later
Megan would have a [ __ ] fit about
socialism on the view the McCain's own
thirteen cars their budget for household
employees was two hundred and seventy
three thousand dollars a year in August
John picks Sarah Palin to be his VP
running mate mmm achievement governor of
Alaska for two years after being a mayor
of a small town John met her once and
spoke to her once on the phone before
picking her there appeared to be no
vetting by his campaign I think that
that's safe to say
Palin had tried to get her former
brother-in-law a state trooper fired as
governor she spent over thirteen
thousand and taxpayer funds to attend
ten religious events and meetings with
Christian pastors she even build the
state for visits to her own church well
I mean we know what we're dealing with
she's an American treasure yeah I mean
just sure something special Palin was a
joke to the media routinely mocked and
came across as rather stupid in
interviews she couldn't name books she
had read she'll that doesn't gotcha
question yeah she could name Supreme
Court justices well that's a gotcha
question she would say absurd things but
her anti intellectualism and disrespect
for facts began to be cheered by the GOP
base john still seemed the decent
maverick liberals thought he was at the
beginning of the campaign when it was
closed he had ruled out going after
obama for his relationship with Reverend
Jeremiah Wright who if you want to go
read his quotes read that go to the
Jeremiah Wright controversy and you can
read the quotes for why he was
considered to be crazy and they're all
remarkably spot-on he said stuff like
well 9/11 happened because the chickens
came home to roost
which is why 9/11 happened yeah but
we're not allowed to talk about right
can't say the truth yeah
when a conservative radio host at a
rally called Obama Hussein three times
John held the press conference to
apologize quote it will never happen
again
but then the financial crisis hit John
suspended his campaign and went back to
DC saying he was going back to help fix
the problem but when he got there he had
no plan and he had no idea what to do
and Republicans were making things
difficult and John ended up looking like
an idiot he plummeted in the polls and
then his campaign went dirty Senator
Lindsey Graham said quote the campaign
would go down in history as stupid if
they don't unleash Sarah Palin and Sarah
Palin was unleashed she went after Obama
as an American and very suspect John
hired the two guys in 2000 who had run
the campaign against him claiming
Bridgette was his quote black love child
now they ran ads claiming Obama
supported teaching sex ed to
kindergartens
and in the ads they darkened his skin in
a lot of McCain's ads Obama's skin was
darkened the campaign became a
smorgasbord of racist dog whistles Obama
was all but flat-out called a Muslim
terrorist or an agent's and to overthrow
the US government the trick was simple
make Obama appear on American which was
easy to do because of his name and his
skin color Palin quote this is not a man
who sees America as you see America and
I see America our opponent is someone
who sees America it seems as being so
imperfect that he's paddling around with
terrorists who would target their own
country
it's so [ __ ] racist McCain's campaign
put out an ad saying Obama was
associated with a domestic terrorist
Bill Ayers of The Weather Underground
from the 60s McCain quote the American
people know a radical when they hear it
and John McCain is not the candidate in
this election they should be concerned
about he said the American black guy he
said I don't know why you're doing that
in Ross pres way she's doing John
McCain's voice I don't have a John
McCain I got Ross Perot though ah John
McCain taint me he said the American
people had to know the full extent of
Obama's relationship with Ayers the
McCain campaign contacted a man whose
home had been blown up back in the day
in the weather ground was suspected yeah
it was that guy he bought my house the
man put out a statement quote Barack
Obama's friend tried to kill my family
oh my god dude I mean can we the
Maverick the Liberals friend John McCain
the campaign sent out flyers with mug
shots of Ayers
and the words terrorist radical friend
of Obama rallies now had speakers saying
Obama's middle name or as John said
quote it will never happen again
from an ad quote think about how you
feel on November 5th if you see the news
that Barack Hussein Obama is President
of the United States ads asked quote who
is Barack Obama and reminded the
audience's of his terrorist connections
1ad quote how dangerous sure these ideas
have been around for a while and the
crazy corners of the
Internet but now a GOP presidential
candidate was saying them and giving
them credence John McCain was
legitimizing the right-wing fringe
madness just kind of lifting the lid on
Pandora's box
now when John took the stage people
yelled out treason traitor terrorists
off with his head
one woman yelled out quote he's a bomb
at a Reb bomb Obama yeah he's gonna go
in and blow up the country he's gonna
take over the White House and destroy
the country yeah at a rally Palin blamed
Katie Couric for making her look stupid
and the crowd turned on the press
screaming at reporters okay and a camera
crew the sound man was black a man
yelled quote a racial epitaph at him and
said quote sit down boy
they wore sarah kuda t-shirts Palin said
Obama was part of a quote group that
launched a campaign of bombings that
would target the Pentagon and our US
Capitol I mean a man in the audience
yelled quote kill him
she did not respond and went on quote
Obama doesn't like American soldiers
still Obama won it was not close yes but
we'll put a pin in this rhetoric well
the damage was done wasn't it the path
was laid this was the first time people
saw the right riled up and what will
become normal under Trump John's
campaign was literally the path for
Trump John remained a senator and went
back to his normal at maverick ways on a
night in August 2009 he tweeted quote
late evening with Colonel Qaddafi at his
ranch in Libya interesting meeting with
an interesting man he left out that he
had offered to sell weapons to Qaddafi
and ensured him the u.s. wanted to
provide Libya with let weapons for
security john was reelected in November
his faithful his fifth term in the
Senate less than two years later as the
Arab Spring
moved to Libya in 2011 John
enthusiastically supported removing a
guy named Qaddafi from power hmm isn't
that his buddy he made numerous visits
to rebel strongholds and then this led
to a NATO backed no-fly zone in a
bombing campaign
eventually his rebel friends sodomized
Qaddafi to death in the streets Libya
would become one of those images that
just sticks
he's not great Libya would become a
bastion of extremism with open slave
markets that operate today John spent
years pushing for the CIA to send
weapons different grips in Syria while
visiting the country pose for a
photograph with a group of men he should
he said should be given weapons two of
the men in the photograph or later ID'd
as men who had kidnapped 11 Lebanese
Shiite pilgrims John spoke and spokesman
said that was quote unfortunate we're
gonna file this one in two oopsie okay
in 2013 I'm gonna [ __ ] bunch of this
name Iran's former President Mohammed
[ __ ] Dean
I'm Edmund - John Ahmed I know John
Aaron for three said he wanted to become
the first Iranian to go to space John
tweeted quote so Ahmed I know John wants
to be the first Iranian in space wasn't
he just there last week and then he
linked to a story about Iran launching a
monkey into space oh my god he's a
maverick stop saying that
an hour later John is what what is it
well it's racist
oh so the guy who voted five times
against MLK Day might be racist maybe an
hour later John tweeted quote regarding
Iran space tweet lighten up folks can't
everyone take a joke
in November 2014 he was reelected to a
six that that's a problem with a lot of
those like I don't want to say like
right-wing but like fringe lunatics is
that the jokes they're not funny right
like there's no humor to the jokes
there's just like there's that you're
just it's just offensive yeah it's just
offensive and punching them that's all
it is okay just wanted to get that up
it's great if you're saying it's great
yeah yeah yeah exactly
so he's elected to a sixth term in his
entire career he never won an election
without massively out spending his
opponents in the run up to the 2016
election John said in an interview that
the Republicans Senate would never vote
to seat a Hillary Clinton Supreme Court
justice if she won hmm
hmm interesting yes because of Merrick
garland well right but everyone loves
him right in 2015 while the Secretary of
Defense John Kerry was in the Ukraine
trying to broker a peace deal
John was in Congress pushing a bill to
arm the Ukrainian government against
Obama's policy so undermining the policy
of the president because he wanted to
and because he's black in July yes in
July 2017 John learned he had an
aggressive brain tumor the Republican
Senate was voting to kill Obama's health
care plan John flew out Oh John flew out
to cast the deciding vote to allow
debate to proceed so if he'd gone out
and voted for debate not to proceed it
would have ended everything right there
but what he did was he flew out and
voted for debate to proceed on Obamacare
whether or not to kill it but that did
that vote not come that vote did not
come down to McCain's vote as to whether
or not what was that I believe was to
get out of committee or something but I
remember his vote he he he he was
deciding vote on whether or not they
should keep debating about Obamacare so
he could have flown out and voted to
stop the debate on Obamacare being
reversed and that would have been the
end of it right but he didn't do that he
voted to continue the debate half
maverick which means that for a few days
everyone in America is terrified and
being basically held under just complete
fear that they will lose their health
care he also gave a speech about how bad
the parties were and criticized
Democrats were passing Obama care in the
first place
on July 28th the Republicans put a
repeal bill to stop parts of Obamacare
together john rolled into the senate
walked up this is what I was thinking
gave a big thumbs down killing the bill
liberals went crazy for this move the
Maverick had done it again liberals did
not seem to notice senators Makowski and
Collins had also voted no repeatedly
yeah the media was all
the Maverick again Vox and other liberal
media companies lost their minds at the
greatness of John in 2015 he had voted
for a bill to gut Obamacare as Medicaid
expansion oh and he had just voted for
the Republicans previous attempt to
repeal the bill but now he's a hero
because he voted out of spite against
Trump but the media that John get away
with everything in September 2017 he was
interviewed by a Jake jack is Jacob Jack
Tapper Jake Jake Jake Tapper about North
Korea John said quote if Kim onion acts
in aggressive in an aggressive fashion
the price will be extinction one would
think of santur casually making a remark
about genocide would lead to a follow-up
question by tapper now he just moved on
to Dhaka so is the life of John McCain
John died from brain cancer on August
25th 2018 after all after he died
liberals sent around a video on social
media of a time that showed what a great
man John McCain was he was in Minnesota
during the campaign against Obama and a
woman called Obama quote an Arab and
John corrected her no ma'am he's a
decent family man citizen that I just
happen to have disagreement
disagreements with on fundamental issues
and that's what this campaign is all
about so first point he just he didn't
defend o Arabs at all he acted like
they're all bad the second point this
was a moment of his own making this is
the height of he and Palin calling Obama
terrorists and putting out ads saying he
was unamerican and putting out ads in
which he was making him seem darker
skinned and calling him a [ __ ]
terrorist
he had one moment of near decency in the
middle of a heinous campaign and this is
what people decide to pass around the
next day on a phone call with reporters
one of McCain's national security
advisors rattled off a list of villains
who supported Obama including Iran's
Ahmed imogen and Hamas and the Riddler
John McCain was literally laying the
path for Trump at the end of his
campaign he began insinuating that the
election result was rigged for Obama
and and clearly Trump watched all this
an argument can be made that John McCain
may have done more damage to this
country than any American in history
because Trump followed his path the
Maverick how do you feel about John
McCain now go get milkshake
man what this story is is the story of
the worst media in the [ __ ] world
Jake Tapper Vox all these [ __ ]
are not doing their job and pieces of
[ __ ] are being repeatedly elected and
put into office and their [ __ ]
monsters and they get to get away with
it and do it repeatedly the I mean that
the truth is that there's always gonna
be liars and evil people oh the bridge
we have is that media tells us what's
going on and who's good and who's bad
and who yeah and there they umpire it
and now at this point they'd rather be
in the players locker room than in the
stands I mean I remember I remember the
election and I remember feeling super
uncomfortable watching the rallies but
until I started reading again and going
the McCain ones yeah until I start
reading again and going through the
transcripts and going and looking at
some videos and watching what had
actually happened
I totally had lost the connection that
oh that's exactly what Trump did there
is no difference between the campaign
that McCain ran in the last month and a
half and the McCain and the Trump there
is no difference particularly when it
comes to Sarah Palin but calling him a
terrorist you know all the the racist
[ __ ] when Palin attacking the media for
attacking the rename that asking
questions is out of line and as much as
John McCain wants to act like he
pick the wrong person he engaged in all
that [ __ ] he approved all that [ __ ] yeah
he's the one who put out ads saying he
was a terror yeah McCain's McCain's a
[ __ ] evil [ __ ] and he set
this up as much as people want to say
it's about racism if John McCain doesn't
do that to those people come out of the
woodwork if they're not lit if they
don't feel that the government that
their that their highest their highest
elected official is is is using their
speech and pushing their agendas do they
do they come out does Trump make that
move because for every guy that does
something there's enough someone is
always putting a path down and and the
truth is that it's like yeah it's it is
it's the foundation because it's like
it's like a lot of stuff and hyper hyper
normalization where it's like the way
this stuff starts and escalates like it
didn't start with suicide bombings it
started with someone throwing a bomb in
a crowded area right and then all of a
sudden you know they have someone has an
idea to actually just like convince
people that you go to heaven if you put
a bomb on yourself and then that's stir
and then it's just like that evolves
further and further and that becomes
commonplace and then you have like
suicide like it all it just all starts
with a wish it all starts with one kooky
thinker who's just like you ask why I
ask why not Jesus God okay so I'm gonna
give this speech like three weeks ago
the IPCC put on a report that is the
basically the UN group about a hundred
fifty-five climate scientists and they
are pretty conservative and what they
usually put out and they and they
basically said we have 10 years to
change what we're doing we have 10 years
to stop using the amount of carbon or
using and to change the way that we
exist on this planet and if we don't
change that in 10 years it's over at
that point we spiral out
control and our children live in a hell
world in 15 60 years so you know the
other day my son my son has we were
driving and he said hey I want to when I
get older I want to own a house and I'm
gonna get married and I want to play
baseball now my first thought was well
you're and he said he wanted have kids
two kids and my first thought was well
you're not gonna have children because
if what we're doing occurs in ten years
no one's going to have children because
look what's happened in California now
in and that's from the pollution we put
in the atmosphere in the 90s we haven't
even gotten to the pollution we put in
the atmosphere today that comes in 25
and 30 years so we have to do something
we are controlled by fossil fuel
companies and a GOP that doesn't believe
in science is out of their [ __ ] minds
and a media that doesn't give a [ __ ]
because they're also controlled by big
corporations so we came up with this
group it's called planet change 10 PLA n
IT change 10 right now right yeah right
now there's a Facebook group and a
there's a reddit a subreddit there's a
Twitter there's gonna be more things
we'll put it will do a web page like we
have to talk to organizers but we want
people to go sign up now here's the idea
everyone's trying to have this
discussion on an intellectual level and
there's no way to combat the [ __ ]
and stupidity and nonsense that comes
back at scientists and scientists has
done the job scientists approved that
climate change is happening there's no
debate anymore there's no questions to
ask the only people are debating are the
oil companies and and if you don't
believe in that then you shouldn't
believe in air or like the ground or
grass it's just something that is the
argument also has changed so much all
the time there are you
was there's no doesn't exist oh no not
man-made and now it's shifting into hey
it's too late sorry right so so the
fight is something we need to undertake
a scientist has done the job and that's
time for people to take over and people
to communicate and and what's happening
out there is people are scared like when
I talk to my when I talk to my kid I'm
[ __ ] devastated and and I feel bad
about his future and and there's a lot
of parents out there that way and
there's a lot of kids I know that go to
sleep crying high school kids I've
gotten three letters after we started
talking about this from high school kids
who say they're bursting into tears all
the time that's the world we're creating
and it's not even there yet and we're
not even as bad as it's going to get so
so what we want to do is use put bring
people together because there's a
psychological thing that happens when
people learn about how bad this is and
they shut down and it's pretty well
documented so it makes it hard to
communicate and it makes it hard for
people to do anything and be active so
our idea is to get people into groups in
each city or in in each different place
and it can be you can be there in person
we can do meetings where people get
together we can just do meetings online
but the idea is to get people talking
about how [ __ ] scared they are and
and be honest about this [ __ ] and be
honest about what's happening to you and
how you feel and in those groups will be
artists we want to bring artists in and
we want artists to be inspired to use
that fear to create art and that can be
videos that can be you know just
drawings paintings whatever and we just
start putting the art out there and the
arts message is we are [ __ ] scared
shitless and you don't care about our
children because there is no other way
to combat it intellectually
let's hit people in their heart so
that's what we're doing it's it's called
planet change ten PLA n IT change 10 and
we'd like people to go sign up and we'd
like to get as many people involved in
this and get something going
yeah you think of that Doomsday Clock
part of the problem is that it hasn't
struck midnight yet like it allows us
like there's still time to crunch for
the exam and like there's not there's
not I mean you know a town in California
was just wiped off the map and and and
there was this great there's a really
great scientist called Daniel Sloan and
he he's a really really smart dude and
he put up some tweets that explained why
it happened and it's purely climate
change it's a hundred percent it's not
it's not the management of the forest
it's not it's it's one or two percent
climate change and this is what it is
this is what we're gonna live with you
you towns burning down also the idea of
like the idea that like it is
culpability falls on one thing it's it's
just like the time to argue and mince
words over like what is causing fires
that are wiping out towns yeah you know
it's it's all of them yeah like but the
one thing that you know isn't always
going to be a creator and a starter of
this stuff is the thing that we can
change which is manmade climate change
which is what all this this [ __ ] is and
I think we can change stuff if we if we
hit people in their hearts yeah and
their their stomach well and the truth
is that it's all like that's what I mean
with the Doomsday Clock the [ __ ] is
going to hit the fan we're just like
well it hasn't hit yet well clean the
[ __ ] out of the fan once it hits the fan
it's like hitting the fan yeah and
there's no technical there's no tech
Savior coming that's [ __ ] every
scientist who knows anything is like no
that's garbage it would also be nice to
actually just treat the earth well for
the sake of just taking care yeah we've
got [ __ ] solar we got wind let's get
it going yeah all right thank you
everybody thanks Aaron great call on how
to pronounce my food a demon John's name
we sign cars hybrid ones